what is the story with the hobbs and
shaw sequel
how have how have you guys not started
making this
i have no idea i don't know
um we just sort of uh we sit around and
wait
for someone to go that you know it's a
big expensive movie remember that
i mean the hundreds of millions of
dollars
get spent on making the movie and
promoting the movie so
they have to have a good script uh and
you know we're we're we're motivated to
do something about that we're we're just
waiting for the right
we're waiting for the knock on the door
essentially uh
i got it do you think that um shaw will
make an appearance
in the final two fast and furious movies
um you want me to tell you yeah i mean
i don't want to get you in trouble but i
do want to know i'd love to come back
for those
you know a couple of movies uh it's very
it's
it's thin ice that i'm skating on if i
talk about
you know what's going to happen in the
next movies but uh
you know i know justin justin lin are
known really well
and we know it was funny when i came on
to do the
uh the cameo got six
uh he never turned up to seven and eight
and they're the ones that i did so
we're destined to do you know something
bigger
and you know you know it's great to work
within and all the other characters i've
made some great friends on that movie
and uh
i really love the film franchise itself
i think it's a global
success for all the right reasons you
know to be a part of it is just a great
privilege so if they uh
if they want me in the next ones i'll be
there but